all right we're live Sean you look nice
we're both updating our Studios looks
like yours got done first
yeah sorry to uh
steal the show but we switched it
already so I don't know what I don't
know what else to do the grand reveal
would have been cooler if we both did it
at the same time but whatever well
that's all right it's yours isn't
entirely done mine's gonna get mine's
getting worked on this weekend dude so
basically for the listeners we're making
our Studios look nice whatever and it's
like totally limiting my options for
like my lifestyle like I like I'm now
thinking about this I'm like oh [__] I
need a bigger house so I can have like
uh you know a guest room as well as a
podcasting room uh as well as like
potential baby rooms it's it's in like
what if you want to travel this freaking
podcaster no like like poor B I can't
travel for two months at a time
or you can just do it in both houses
dude I'm thinking about like my
lifestyle and like where I want to live
which I've talked about a lot on here
um I don't know what to do I I don't
know where I'm gonna end up I don't know
what I'm gonna do it's driving me mad
yeah by the way we should do a episode
that explains how we thought through
when we when we do the the full Studio
when the whole thing's done like mine's
like you know 70 done yours is zero
percent done so far when we're done we
should do an episode explaining you know
how we thought about it how we pulled it
how we did it without a big headache all
the [__] we bought how much it all cost
uh we should do a full breakdown as a
separate like video on YouTube all right
I'm down yeah we gotta and we'll pimp
out the guy who did it Kevin uh yeah but
yeah we can do that okay cool let's jump
into uh what topics you got you want to
go first
um all right I'll start off with
something interesting I want to give an
award
that I'm calling the Chad bro chill
award to this guy named Eric Langan
um so listen to this guy's story I just
randomly came across those because my uh
my friend Alex showed it to me but it's
kind of like a true rag to riches
American Dream story so hear me out
so this guy named Eric he's um 21 years
old and he starts dating this woman and
she sees that uh her her place of work
is not exactly treating her respectfully
and he says you know where should this
woman works I think this is an
interesting business and I think if I
created a business that treated my
employees a little bit better I think I
could retain them better and Build a
Better Business
so he's 21 years old somehow he's
accumulated all this this these really
nice baseball cards over the past 10
years of collecting he takes him to a
convention he sells his baseball cards
and he now has 44 000 in cash and he
goes I'm going to go and start my
business and what is that business it's
a strip club he was dating a stripper
and this guy Eric he he
done with the story enjoyed that yeah
yeah so he takes this company and he
like buys he has one strip club he
starts another eventually he takes it
public yes this is a publicly traded
company that owns a bunch of strip clubs
and that symbol is Rick it's just Rick
[Music]
foreign
so now at this point it's 800 million
dollar market cap and it's basically a
free cash flow like a wonderful cash
flowing yeah a wonderfully cash flowing
company it's 800 million dollars in
market cap does something like 300
million in revenue and like 80 million
in cash flow and it's kind of
interesting because
they just basically buy Mom and Pop
strip clubs which is I don't know if
that's like an oxymoron but just pop and
pop yeah yeah something like that yeah
you know just like you're just like your
standard you know local mom and pop
strip club he buys them for one or two
times Revenue puts a little operational
process in there and he's also got a
crazy clientele where guys like Drake
and Pitbull and all these people like
rap about his strip clubs you know and I
want to be honest I've only been to one
strip club in my life I went to one
strip club ever it was in Vegas like
four years ago have you ever been to a
strip club same story I have actually a
funny story with this so we go to the uh
for the first time to a strip club I
think 21 years old maybe and um
you know I didn't know what to expect I
didn't know if this was the start of a
new hobby or if this was you know the
start of a bad day and and so we go
um you know in Vegas there's the guys on
the street who are like boys looking
handsome you guys want you know free
limo free drinks and you're like yeah no
questions yeah yeah yeah that sounds
like a good offer I have no further
questions we get in this limo we're like
hey do we get to choose where it goes
it's like nah
this like Place five miles away and
you're gonna go into our establishment
and so we we get dropped off at this
place we're like I guess we're at a
strip club now like wow I guess we
probably should have thought that one
through we go in and it's it's four
friends
and um my buddy I won't say their names
but uh so we go in and I'll just tell
you the characters there's me I'm the
the the group uh I'm like the jester I'm
just I'm just there to make jokes and
I'm like oh this is this I'm gonna
Thrive here there's gonna be so much so
much funny material but I'm not the
I'm not the one who's sort of the most
I'm not the most prude I'm not the most
kind of aggressive when it comes to to
women there's one guy who's like The
Ladies Man everybody this guy always
gets all the girls and when we go to the
strip club we're just sort of expecting
him to take the lead it's like yo ball's
in your court here you you tell us
you're the man you tell us boys what to
do and then we have one guy who's been
in a relationship for like 95 years just
got out uh it looks like a dad and we
were like you know okay you just stay at
the back you're not gonna know what to
do here you've been in a relationship
for 95 years we walk in and within two
minutes we're like Hey we're Dad where'd
the dad go like he's gone and we see him
while we were nervously just like
ordering drinks at the bar like as if
that's why we came to this strip club
was like to go get a drink at the bar uh
and we're using the free coupons the guy
gave us up from the street
um we're like trying to tear them and be
like does this count two of any drink
and like really what's a spirit
technically like you know because I plus
any spirits and then we're like where'd
he go and then we see him holding hands
with a stripper walking to the back
we're like the back we can't even see
him anymore we don't know what I'm like
how does he know what to do back there
uh we were all just like you know
befuddled but now we're all like sort of
like challenged it's like okay challenge
accepted uh we don't see this guy for
like 45 minutes so we let 15 minutes go
by we assume he's gonna come back this
guy's nowhere to be found and we're like
what is going on what is he doing back
there and then so we kind of get nervous
we go back and so each of us
picks a stripper and we all we each go
to the back so ladies man goes with the
you know so I'm super hot like in the
same room no we don't know you just go
behind this curtain now we don't know I
don't know where my friend is I don't
know if I'll ever see him again so
ladies man takes the hottest stripper
goes in the back
spoiler he ends up falling in love with
her he literally falls in love with a
stripper he's like dude she's the best
and like he's like but he's like no
that's not about her looks like her
heart was so pure
that's what happened to him that night I
go back with one but now they've got
three kids and I'm like so how does this
work here I got questions you know me
right
so I start I'm like how does this work
what does this do do I sit here can I
sit anywhere like um and I'm like do I
tell you or you tell me like who's in
charge and I'm at so many questions she
literally asked me if I'm a cop because
and I'm like no I'm just a curious guy
so that's my experience back there I
just use it as an interview an
unrecorded podcast basically and then
our buddy the dad finally comes out
we're all done we all just like 15
minutes 75 dollars later we're like I I
don't know what the hell just happened I
I've spent all my money and he comes out
and we're like dude what what happened
back there and he told us two things so
we go we asked him two questions we said
where did you go for so long and how did
you have the confidence to do that and
the second was why'd you pick her
because she was like not she was like
you know she was not the best looking
you know uh in the bunch and so he goes
oh I just asked her for a tour
lap dance no no way and I was like oh
you TR we thought you were doing
something cool and then we all got peer
pressured and it turns out we were wrong
second we were like why'd you pick her
he goes oh I didn't know you get to
choose he goes I thought it's like Harry
Potter like the one chooses the wizard
that was like the Epic line and so
forever
whenever you end up making a bad
decision
that's hilarious I actually lied I I
didn't remember the first time I went to
a strip club it was Neville Medora my
buddy Annette in Texas was taking me to
my Thursday 6 p.m flight and he goes
let's actually go at two I want to let's
go out to eat I go all right cool
because I got I got the perfect place in
mind and so he takes me to a strip club
next to the Austin Texas airport called
The Landing Strip at three o'clock uh on
a Thursday and we get there and I'm like
what uh what do we do and I remember and
he's like well let's just get lunch or
something and so I ordered like chicken
Breakers and fries and the lady comes up
to me as I'm sitting down like puts my
like her hand on my shoulders like hey
you need anything and I was like uh yeah
like ketchup some ketchup ketchup would
be nice and she look is like all like
defeated and brings the ketchup and and
I remember texting my girlfriend at the
time now wife and I was like hey Sarah
I'm at a strip club we're just getting
lunch do I like tip them extra because I
didn't all I did was ate lunch it was
only six dollars like what do we do
um it was the same thing incredibly
awkward situation very uncomfortable but
I care I read it I read about this
company and I thought how interesting
and this guy his name's Eric he um the
CEO of the company is called um what's
it called it's called um Rich uh it's
called Rick's that's their that's their
ticker it's called RCI Hospitality
Holdings the CEO is pretty present on um
on social media his his Twitter handle I
think is Rick's CEO and um and so you
know he's he's pretty active and I think
the other thing that's interesting is uh
like we were gonna do this for the milk
road because strippers know a recession
is coming before anybody and so we were
going to spend our Rider to talk about
like hey what's going on in the markets
I was like oh just go to a strip club
and just ask the strippers they'll tell
you like we'll be one week ahead of the
news and he's like what I was like yeah
they know like the tips they understand
like what's going on they know the
psychology and the state the psyche of
all men and then they they know where
they're at financially as well dude well
he does his earnings call on Twitter uh
at one time he did it and the host was
liquidity that Twitter guy and he does
this
I don't know but Elon Musk was like was
sat through one of the earnings calls
and it's incredibly interesting he's
also trying to they're also coming out
with a uh like a new like only fans
thing called admire me which is like an
only fans but for their dancers he calls
them entertainers and so like if you're
an Entertainer at the strip club you
know you can uh like create a small side
hustle with your clients and I just
thought this was like I was like well
this this is like a pretty fascinating
uh pretty fascinating business I never
heard of I've never in a million years
thought a strip club conglomerate would
be publicly traded and
pretty fascinating pretty fascinating
company
yeah um all right well I don't have much
to add the sort of Juan chooses the
wizard was my the ending of my knowledge
so at that point I I retired from the
game by the way are you doing something
for Black Friday
like for your like with my family
are you like selling discounts and stuff
what as an e-commerce owner what's your
opinion on Black Friday
so I I think I'm doing it wrong because
everybody else is like Black Friday
Black Friday biggest time of the year
people are sending memes in the group
chat that's like uh like you know the
300 the Spartans when they're charging
and they're like we're ready we're ready
for Black Friday and for two years in a
row Black Friday has been
you know a big disappointment and um the
reason why I think
I guess like
people think about Black Friday it
should be what it should be is like
basically November should be double your
other sales month so you should kind of
get a 2X with that 2x you're gonna have
a lot of profit so like that's I think
that's why they call it Black Friday
because you end up in the black
um I don't know if that's true or not
but like yeah that's somebody told me
that can you just pick that up you
generate a lot of your profit for the
year during this kind of like this this
last push of the Year this is how you go
from the red to the black and um I think
it requires you know a large like you
know repeat customer base so Black
Friday is basically an excuse It's a
sort of a trick in the mind of a
consumer that like it's a license to
spend when you didn't even need to spend
and um so you get a lot of returning
customers coming back so without having
to do more marketing necessarily you're
gonna get them back but you're also
steeply discounting then if you're
marketing at all like you have your
marketing spends you have your discount
spent so I'm like where where is all
this profit that other people speak of
hasn't worked for us we've had way
bigger months outside of November both
years uh this this year's doing good but
like
I don't know I don't I don't get all the
fusses about I like it more as a
consumer than I do as an Ecom store
owner
um but then again
I might just be a crappy operator and
there might just be like a better way to
do it but I'm doing it they're like the
best practice thing you know I'm sending
an email every like 42 minutes it's like
you know that's what you got to do is
just keep spamming the hell out of
everybody discount the things like crazy
and um you know hope and pray people
show up do you buy stuff as a consumer
for Black Friday yeah I um I shop you
know uh that Brand's 32 heat or 32 cool
but like Costco Costco performance wear
brand no but that's awesome you must
know these guys basically there's like a
I think it's I don't know if they're
made by Costco or they're sold in Costco
but it's called 32 degrees is the name
of the brand and so they make like you
know like a Under Armor or Lululemon
style thing but like the cheap version
but on Black Friday these guys have had
the most ridiculous sale like you'll
just get a shirt for four dollars or six
dollars that's normally like you know 30
so it's like 80 off they just move they
just try to move all their inventory
during this part of the year and so for
the last couple years I have dropped
like 500 and bought like an ungod like
huge boxes arrive at my house like it's
furniture and inside is just 32 Degree
stuff that I just give out to my whole
family and I wear you know throughout
the year but uh that's the only thing I
did on Black Friday and then sometimes
I'll go scroll Amazon and see what they
got dude I think we need a boycott Black
Friday Black Friday is the worst I think
it's just we are people buy you know
George Carlin said this funny thing he's
got this whole like skit it's a famous
comedian on on stuff and he's like a
house is just basically a pile of stuff
with a cover on it and you buy a second
house it's really just so you can store
more crap you can store more stuff I I
am so anti-stuff at this point in my
life I don't want to buy more stuff and
we need to get like all MFM listeners to
just boycott Black Friday I hate this
idea of buying stuff that you don't
really need that just then you got to go
and pay more money that you know what's
the worst the biggest kick in the ass is
when you gotta pay money to have someone
come and throw away the boxes of of all
the stuff that you bought off Amazon
that is the worst feeling I cannot stand
that and I refuse to do it now I have a
trash can that's a metal trash can that
I just burn it all I hate buying more
stuff I cannot stand all this stuff that
we buy on Black Friday and I refuse to
do it and I think we got to get everyone
to not do it actually burn your trash
yeah yeah I have I have videos of me
doing it because Sarah Sarah like has
this like funny meme that she shares
with our family it's like you know no
matter what happens we can't we're never
gonna change them but uh dude I'm not
paying money to throw away Amazon boxes
I refuse to do that that's crap yeah I
paid like 600 to have uh 100 junk like
come haul away a bunch of boxes for crap
that I bought so it's the worst I'm not
gonna do it but
um like this isn't Vietnam you can't
just like go burn your trash this is not
India you can't do that I I think
legally you can I think you can you're
allowed to have a little you're allowed
to have fires in your yard
wow incredible
um I want to talk to you about uh
Twitter so shocker this Twitter thing
that's playing out with Elon running
Twitter is um
wildly entertaining and I guess I just
think there's two things I want to say
the first is you know before when I
heard about Elon Musk and how he did
things
um I admired him but there was a part of
me that felt bad it's like man
I'm just a lame duck compared to this
guy like this guy's achieving the
incredible this guy is
um you know must be just this execution
machine he must be this like strategic
genius
and now that I see him running Twitter I
don't feel so bad after all I don't feel
the edge has been taken off a little bit
are you up from like if we if there's a
scale and all the way to the left is AOC
and all the way to the right it's just
total Fanboy where do you rank
I'm more towards AOC but it's not like
so black and white like uh right
obviously the guy is super smart
obviously he's super successful
obviously he's done some amazing things
and he's built some really amazing
products that those are I mean
inarguable
um
I find him corny and I find him to be a
virtue signaler uh and as sometimes he
gets them like crossed you know like he
gets his signals crossed he'll be like
you know um
you know it'd be like like uh yesterday
he tweeted something out like there he
like reinstated Trump and they were like
yo why don't you reinstate Alex Jones
yeah I saw that and he was like he's
like then he like wrote a poem and then
the guy was like what and then he wrote
a poem about like you know the suffering
of children blah blah and then they go
no but really like by the same logic of
why you would reinstate one person why
would you not reinstate you know Alex
Jones you know what I don't agree with
him but I'm just curious about that
policy decision and he goes um you know
uh my first child uh died in my arms I
felt her last heartbeat and I will never
uh you know so I can't I I will never
allow somebody who promo who like used
the suffering of children for profit or
fame or gain in some way right
um Fair sentiment okay great very
emotional sentiment you know that's fine
but at the same time constantly be
talking about free speech and and like
how uh you know it shouldn't be one
person deciding you know whatever it's
like well that's you now deciding you
know where you're Drawing the Line off
of your random personal experience that
traumatic and sad
you know it's a little bit strange right
so like you know whether you disagree I
agree with Alex Jones is sort of
irrelevant it's just sort of like his
virtue signaling about like his like sad
experience got crossed like on the
crossfire with his virtual signaling
about how hardcore he is about free
speech he said this himself I'm hardcore
about Free Speech I'm hardcore that as
long as you're not doing something as
long as you're not like you know uh
breaking the law with what you're saying
then you should be allowed to do this
and so
like there's you know some things there
anyways point is I think he's obviously
really talented he's probably gonna have
us have success with Twitter but um you
know definitely has like you know I
consider myself to be somewhat impulsive
this guy's like impulsive to the Max and
on one hand I think there's like a a
kind of a brilliant method to his
Madness of what he's doing like he
basically came in and just did a
hardcore culture reset he's like
let's just get rid of everybody who's in
charge so day one fired the CF CEO CFO
CMO all of them walked him out the door
all right that's day one the leaders are
shot the leaders you know they're out
next he like basically cut like half the
employees then he cut another half after
that
um trying to be like yo this is gonna be
hardcore work environment and like none
of that soft [__] anymore and like I
think ripping the Band-Aid off the way
he did while harsh and like you know not
that graceful just like doing it via the
email saying like you know reply
hardcore by 3 P.M or you're out
um you know probably could have been a
better way to do it but like nonetheless
if very effective and ballsy so I like
yeah I like that too along with that
comes cutting a bunch of the burn down
so trimming a bunch of the fat making it
a more financially healthy thing but now
I'm like okay
what are the scenarios like how can this
how can this play out like what what are
the different ways that this can go and
like what's the bet and so I kind of
wrote some of these out I'll give you my
uh my three scenarios okay so I'll do
them from and I'll rank if I agree with
with each of the three I'll rank most
likely so you want me to go from worst
to best or best to worse uh uh least
funny to most funny
okay
the base case the expected case so
he makes Twitter more financially viable
right he's cut down costs he um adds
this you know Eight dollar a month
subscription that you know uh let's say
he can make it more and more valuable so
people opt in it makes it a little less
dependent on ad Revenue
um the initial reaction where
advertisers pulled out gets like subdued
a little bit people come back to the
platform they realize okay he's not you
know evil
um or gonna like you know there's not
gonna be other people impersonating
their brand so they come back so he he
resets the culture resets the cost
structure makes it more viable uh makes
it a little more moderate like he gets
rid of a little the like the the
hardcore left lean
um he cleans up some of the bot problem
he gets some like solid wins like oh you
can edit your Tweet you can post long
form videos you can like you know just
make search better he just improves the
product in ways that the power users
will appreciate and the end state is you
know he gets a kind of a one to two x on
his money
um you know from where it is today I
don't think I don't think this is the
likely scenario this is a very this is
far too reasonable this is the
reasonable scenario so yeah and and
personally you know he gets a kind of a
win you know a moral Victory uh you know
it's net positive for the company
Twitter's net positive you know moved in
a positive direction and financially
wasn't disaster no this is like this is
like asking Picasso not to paint or John
London not to make music like it just
that that's just an unreasonable request
regardless if it's if it is in fact
reasonable for most it is incredibly
unreasonable for this human being I'll
say this she he came in and did the hard
part where he gutted the fish and he
changed the culture and he's going to
recruit good talent but he's got but in
order to do this he would need to
replace himself as CEO within the next
six months basically and then that
person stewards it from there he did the
Deep Cuts he did the hardcore like shock
therapy and then somebody's gonna take
it from there if this is going to happen
um because I don't think he's gonna do
that over a three-year span you know
running a steady ship okay
now let's go to the generous scenario
the best case scenario what he says he
wants to do okay so what he says he
wants to do
um if you heard his like stated plan
like what his like goal is with it I
heard where he said he wants to make it
like the
like the Town Square he wants to make it
like an everything app and he wants to
add video and a bunch of other things
like that yeah I think the everything
app is the the strategically what he's
trying to do so what he basically looks
at WeChat and for those who don't know
WeChat is basically WhatsApp
plus YouTube plus Bill Pay Plus Amazon
Plus like everything rolled into one
plus venmo yeah it's hard it's hard to
Fathom if you if you don't use it it's
basically like it's the WeChat is just a
connector between people and then all
the things that people do let's say I
want to send you money I could do that
let's say I want a message a business I
could do that let's say I want to uh pay
my utility bills for the month I could
do that on WeChat let's say I want to uh
post a video or watch a video or
something like that I could do that and
so WeChat is like the super app and
there's been a lot of people that have
been waiting for oh when is this going
to happen in the west and it never
happened like all these things were
siled into different apps and there's
people who sort of are like oh that
sucks to have eight different apps this
should just be one app that just does
all the things everyone nods like yeah
all in one makes sense but then the
reality is like go build the all in one
app people aren't just gonna ditch
you're not gonna be as good at those
things that those other apps specialize
in plus people are just going to change
their habits and just ditch eight apps
for one because you want them to so
so his idea is to create the super app
uh dau's you know daily active users
would need to go from like 200 million
to a billion so it becomes like a
Facebook a WhatsApp a YouTube Twitter
jumps to that like the big boy table
because basically right now Twitter is
of like the 8 or 10 social networks
which include Facebook Snapchat
Instagram WhatsApp Reddit and a few
others it's the least popular in terms
of uh users correct and um and so you
know best I would say the best case
scenario he goes for the super app maybe
some things go his way like maybe Tick
Tock gets banned in the US and Twitter
quickly grabs short form video although
Facebook and YouTube would probably have
something to say about that but like you
know maybe they go for that
um you know he he cleans up the bot
problem he improves the ad platform like
both me and you have tried to run
Twitter ads it's God awful compared to
Facebook and I think it's it's good I
think I think the system sucks like the
actual the system does suck I just I
just bought Twitter ads yesterday and
like I kept getting heirs when I was
trying to set it up uh so like the tech
is bad but a lot of people are saying
that right now because 50 of the top 100
advertisers have pulled back and usage
is all-time high that their CAC is five
or ten times better than it used to be
six months ago oh wow okay that's
interesting that's good good but that's
not necessarily a sustainable thing or a
that's not a win for Twitter that is a
loss for Twitter that is yeah well no
one's using it for their full
advertisers yeah yeah that that's not
actually like a win for them yeah
exactly but let's say he like gets it to
be a Facebook level of AD system
grows it you know he has to figure out
something with short form video or
something that's more appealing like
um but let's say he does it and the end
state is it's now like culturally up
there with all the other social like the
big social networks the the sort of
Facebook's YouTubes uh tick tocks of the
world it you know he turns the profits
around because he's got this lean leaner
team that's doing that and it's like a
10x return and he's the goat everybody's
like God this guy did this too this is
like you know the next level thing now
he owns one of the big social platforms
he single-handedly turned that [__]
around and uh he did what nobody could
do he did what Jack couldn't do he did
what em couldn't do he did what dick
Hustler couldn't do he did it and he did
it like as his third job side hustle
this guy is the goat
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated whoa I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
fairly unreasonable as well I actually
think it's more unreasonable than the
first scenario that you gave right well
it should be because it's like this like
amazing outcome
um okay so now what is the the Bad Case
the worst case scenarios
I think it's basically like there's this
um super cycle like going downwards like
a downward cycle so a lot of what's
happening in crypto right now one thing
in crypto blew up and then people who
had taken loans to invest in that thing
now their loans they're defaulted on
their loans so the people who lent the
money they're out of money they blow up
then the people who had stored their
money with that bank or exchange now
they lose their deposits it's just like
daisy chain of bad news uh all stemming
from a lot of Leverage in the system and
some a few people being Reckless or
fraudulent and so let's say in this case
what it would be is like Tesla stock I
think is down 50 from last year or more
uh he's personally lost 100 billion
dollars of personal net worth
um Tesla stock is not the more attention
he puts on Twitter people feel like he's
taking his eye off the ball so basically
overall economy is going down we had
enter a recession people slow down
buying these like really expensive
Teslas
um
stock is crashing
he still has this interest payment he
owes he owes a billion dollars a year in
just Debt Service on Twitter and I think
Twitter's net profit was less than that
so he can't even currently the profits
from Twitter can't even just pay the
debt let alone any profits above debt
and so let's say advertisers keep
pulling out on the Twitter side uh the
initial Spike from elon's watching
elon's chaos goes away
um maybe he even makes some mistakes
maybe the info maybe they they fired too
many of the infrastructure people
there's the fail whale maybe it gets
hacked because the security system is
now more vulnerable as they make all
these quick impulsive code changes and
they fired a bunch of long time
engineers and so you get maybe hacks
maybe leaks DMS get leaked maybe
um
uh if maybe the site's just going down
meanwhile Tesla Stock's going down
meanwhile he owes all this debt
um if all this starts to happen
basically like a financial sort of like
cave-in occurs and you know Elon ends up
and he's getting sued by ex-employees
he's getting sued by advertisers who
said hey our brand got damaged because
you verified some fake account for eight
dollars that then said you know we don't
like Jewish people or whatever right
like you know that's so he's getting
sued on all ends and Elon ends up you
know fat and broke right so that's the
like worst case scenario on that side
react to that one so you know you and I
both watch UFC and boxing and stuff like
that and there's this like famous
sentiment that says like basically all
nearly all Champions they leave the
career on their back meaning uh if you
don't get out on top which only a few
people have khabib May weather George
Saint Pierre only a few people have
these guys if you don't follow that
these those are like the best people and
they all quit when they were uh winning
if you don't leave at the top which very
few people do you get knocked out and
with the injury that devastates your
life and you end up like Muhammad Ali
and you can't talk and I think that that
is the same what what's true in boxing
and UFC is also true for business and if
we look at history that tends to be the
case of people who keep pushing and
pushing and pushing inevitably you're
going to lose at one point but the
bigger you get if you keep taking these
really big like bet the farm type of
risks
you're just gonna you're you're gonna
lose more and more and more and I think
that there's some examples of like a um
Jeff Bezos saying like all right this is
this this [__] worked you know I
gotta pass on the torch I don't think a
guy like Elon has the ego control in
order to do it and I think that what you
are saying for this final scenario is
more likely to happen than the other two
I don't think he's going to be able to
hand over the reins and I think that
potentially this will be a I don't the
the phrase isn't career ending but like
a uh maybe like a power ending move or
or something like that right a fall from
grace yeah Fall From Grace I think that
could definitely could happen I I think
that even you know you think about a guy
who's worth 100 billion or whatever he
was worth and you think like well
there's no way a person like that can
blow that and I actually think that
regardless of the fortune size you can
blow it and buying a 50 billion dollar
asset that isn't quite working
wonderfully is a really good way to blow
it and I think that I think that that
could be the case here but I don't think
he'll admit because he's just like
he's he's he's crazy I don't think he
can admit admit a lot of like weakness
or fault yeah his core assets Tesla and
SpaceX are like high risk like assets
they're not like um
these you know it's not whatever the
railroad company that's just like
steadily a steady utility company that's
just gonna you know print you know cash
and growth two percent a year uh you
know these are these are these are
themselves pretty volatile assets that
the market has really pumped up
and as the market has turned like those
are going downwards for sure now how
fast and how hardcore and you know if he
keeps selling Tesla stock in order to
keep Twitter alive it's gonna be like
elon's distracted his priority is
Twitter he's selling the stock and what
else is he supposed to do where else
he's supposed to get money in order to
like fund a money burning business like
Twitter and so um
so I think you know there are some
downside scenarios do I do I think he
ends up broke no I think the guy will
never be broke uh do I think that he
goes from where he was richest man in
the world and probably considered the
greatest entrepreneur in the world to
two years from now Twitter ends up as a
disaster maybe bankrupt or sold takes a
you know 20 billion dollar loss there
plus Tesla stock in the meantime has has
lost him maybe another 100 billion
dollars or more and he's no longer the
richest man in the world he's no longer
seen as this you know Iron Man
Invincible type of dude he's been a hit
with lawsuits and me too's and uh you
know news leaks constantly is what I
predict is going to happen in the next
two years for sure it's going to be
he went from Golden Boy to now he's
going to be a guy who can't do anything
right it's just going to be constant
leaks and hit pieces I think for the
next two years for him I think the Elon
case study is not necessarily how smart
a human being is you know I think of
Elon before and I was like this guy's a
genius he's amazing I actually think
it's more a case study it is he is
intelligent I think that there are prop
there's definitely other people as smart
as him I think what this is more so a
case study of the capacity to suffer and
what I am continually shocked by is his
ability to suffer for longer periods of
time and to add more suffering just you
know just like they're just people are
just dumping suffering into his it is in
his truck and they're just tossing it on
there and it's like when is this truck
gonna break and I'm shocked it hasn't so
far but I believe in like there are
everyone has a limit and I'm just
shocked we haven't hit it yet maybe this
is it but it's pretty amazing like if
you talk to people about him I do and
he'll even say he he at one point he
said death would be a relief to me
someone was like are you afraid of dying
he goes no it'll be a relief and I think
that he just has done a decent job of
being funny and laughing in in spite of
suffering but I think that he's lonely
and I think that his life sucks I think
he I had I think he lived a generally
unpleasant unhappy suffering life and um
that's what he's chosen to do and
there's going to be a limit to it and I
think that this could be that limit
I think that is true of all the greats
that were most of the greats right
they're sort of Two Souls uh you know uh
so I think that's that's true for a lot
of people
um one other signal that I think is kind
of in his favor or kind of bullish do
you know this guy George hautes or Hots
love him we got to get this guy in the
Pod this guy is one of those freaks that
I love he is a total freaking Weirdo And
and just he's a punk rocker tell people
his background and then and then I don't
know if you've been following what he's
doing with Twitter but uh so years ago
when Sean and I both lived in San
Francisco I think he started out of like
a hacker house didn't he where like it
was like just a hacker house with a
bunch of like computer guys and he
starts building a self-driving uh not a
self-driving car but technology that you
can add to most cars and it's called
comma dot AI I believe and he starts a
self-driving car and he makes these
crazy predictions and like there's one
story of like a journalist coming to see
his self-driving car technology and he's
driving throughout San Francisco and
they're like this is amazing when did
you get this to work he's like oh just
this morning like he's just like a cow
he's like a cowboy that builds the stuff
that is incredibly illegal uh
unregulated and he just plows through
and he does it anyway raises all this
money it ends up flaring out and not
working out and he quits and leaves but
he's very outspoken very opinionated
clearly a smart guy and a kind of a punk
rocker in terms of like self-driving
cars he makes fun of all his competitors
including like GE and Ford and all this
stuff and so he's kind of a a loose
cannon but it kind of in a good way in
my opinion so two things one I don't
think Kama has has flamed out like I
think it's still going I don't think it
has not become the winner but he did
resign as CEO president or whatever uh
so the company's still alive but before
that you know his backstory I think he
was the first guy to jailbreak an iPhone
um so I think jail broke like a Tesla
too I think he jailbroken iPhone then he
hacked the PlayStation so he hacked Sony
um which was pretty huge and then
um
and then he was doing something with a
Tesla and I remember at the time there
was some story I sorry I don't have this
in front of me but there was some story
where Elon basically offered him
a job or something like that yeah so
Elon offered him it is what he claims
Elon offered him 12 million dollars
minus so basically he said I'll give you
12 million
um
all right let me explain differently he
did a demo that showed he had the
self-driving car technology and it
wasn't using at the time what was the
kind of the core technology for the
vision system which I think was mobile I
mobile I was the hot company that's what
Tesla was using George Holtz made a
version of that without using mobileye
and mobile I was kind of limiting it
kind of sucked and kind of expensive so
Tesla wanted to get off it so he says
that Elon made him an offer which was
I'll give you 12 million dollars for
this technology
minus 1 million for every month that it
takes you to do the task so it's like if
it takes you nine months just a a
pissing match between two uh uh people
ready to take that play that game
exactly exactly and uh he's like if you
can create a driving system that
replaces mobile eye uh that Tesla's
using at the time and then uh they kind
of walked that back and whatever and say
and they they basically discussed you
know do you want to come work whatever
no so then he creates comma.ai which was
the idea was like yo you don't need to
buy a Tesla that has like self-driving
like what about all these other millions
and millions of cars that exist what are
they gonna do just be left in the dust
he's like no I'm going to build a
retrofit system so you could put this on
a Honda Civic and install this thing on
the top and this thing in the dash and
then it it will be able to be
self-driving right like we'll install
the cameras and the in the technology so
that your car can be retrofitted to be
self-driving that was the dream of that
system so he's this hacker guy brilliant
brilliant uh programmer also very very
entertaining guy like he's sort of like
um we've talked about Martin shkreli's
lives streams where he like looks at
stocks and finance and things like that
and then this guy George does the same
thing he'll live stream himself figure
things out so the other day he's the
real deal I think I mean I think that
example's like that you're the re he's I
I don't think he's full of it I think he
I think he's a loose cannon but I think
he's the real deal yeah I agree so the
other day he goes live on um on Twitter
live streaming video and he's like let's
see how Twitter works all right I'm just
gonna like I've never looked at the
Twitter source code but like let's and I
I don't work there so I don't have
access but like just right click inspect
and let's see what they're doing okay so
what is this okay this is the login
prompt what if I remove this and he
starts messing with it he's like so how
does this work and he's like trying to
play with it he's just talking live all
these what platform is this on uh so he
was doing it on Twitter at least he
streamed it live on Twitter as the video
then he goes he does twitch a lot and
things like that
so then he tweets out to Elon he he
tweets out about the hardcore he tweets
out elon's like hardcore email and he's
like this is great this is like exactly
what it takes to win and like you know
people should be jumping on this and
immediately he starts getting backlash
people are like oh yeah you know so this
guy's asking you to work twice as hard
for less money and you know or you know
without giving you extra pay like oh
yeah we should all just be slaves to
this billionaire and people are like
ragging on him in the comments and he
goes dude can you imagine the excitement
of getting to work on this right now
like this is amazing screw it I'll put
my money where my mouth is hey Elon I'll
do a 12-week internship uh I'll work for
free and
um I want to come help you fix Twitter
and he took it Elon goes sure let's talk
and then George goes back you know here
comes the pissing match he goes my
number hasn't changed which is just a
hilarious thing to be like you know you
call me and let's let it be known you
have my number
that's what he said he goes my that's
what his reply was he goes great my
number hasn't changed oh my God and then
so so he agreed to so he's there now so
he joined Twitter
he agreed to Elon gave him the problem
he goes you're gonna fix Twitter search
you have 12 weeks to do it and um so
he's publicly trying to fix Twitter
search right now and he's tweeting out
every day the [__] he's doing and he
agreed to work on this for just the cost
of living stipend I said I think he said
he makes uh he's gonna make uh two two
grand a week I think is what he said the
cost of living San Francisco so eight
grand a month and this is a guy that
like
is a multi-millionaire basically cannot
be hired for a job he's a he's like a
you know an entrepreneur that could snap
his fingers and get funding again well
and he's tweeting as he goes I just saw
him tweet something and the first line
was I don't know if I have the authority
to do this but and then he like said
what he wanted to do and I was like I'm
in you got me that's a beautiful first
sentence I'm following your journey and
one of the things he did he goes all
right I'm trying to fix a search thing
but I need somebody to he wanted
somebody to do like just a front-end
design task which like most programmers
most real programmers aren't good at
that stuff and so he's like I wanted to
just auto complete like you know when I
open search he goes for some reason it
shows me like just this random follower
of my name he's like no it should prompt
me on the ways that I can search like
search
people search for hashtag search for my
search within my likes like show me what
the things I could do he goes don't send
me a resume don't tell me it can't be
done uh just send me a code snippet that
I can plug in and it works if you do
that you're hired that's the interview
so it's wildly entertaining to watch
this guy do it and I think this is part
of the bull case of
well if Elon can get like real hackers
and real people who are like ready it's
kind of like a movie when it's like oh
the old Gunslinger they go to his house
he's retired but he agrees to dust off
the old boots and get back out there
like okay we have a final mission for
you yeah exactly like if he could have
told you I'm retired yo this is Ocean's
11. we're gonna go do this [__] it's
like a three month gig just get off your
ass and come do this it's also the bear
case though because
that sounds great and all when you're
just getting something going it doesn't
sound good when I have all types of
private stuff in my DMs that I would not
want to be public uh you know I share
like intimate things like you know like
I'll complain about other people or I'll
like say like hey how are you solving
this problem I can't figure it out I
don't like the fact that people are are
doing things this way when there's
already 300 million users and there's a
lot of like payment information and like
intimate information on this platform so
I would say it's also a bear case yeah
by the way on that he so Elon goes all
the messaging should be encrypted I
should if a gun was to my head I should
not be able to reveal what's in
somebody's DMS so we need to go
end-to-end encryption and he told the
employees that then he goes and then I
have same thing
I reached out to the original founder of
signal he's willing to help us you know
like think through how to do this you
know like like help us implement this
end encryption quickly and um same thing
he's like you know basically like oh
that guy that the guy from who started
signal he sold he was the guy from
WhatsApp right sold it to
Facebook
um then regretted it and was like F this
these guys are like basically screwing
with my baby they're they're reducing
the encryption they're adding in ads
they're mining the data whatever quits
out of principle and starts signal a
like completely encrypted messaging tool
because he like really believes in this
um I forget if he's the one who founded
it or he was the funder he was maybe the
main main funding so yeah whatever he
was involved he was involved he put like
50 million in
um
but yeah that's the uh that's another
example of people you know getting
getting kind of like world-class people
involved but do you realize Somebody's
gotta go do the work every day for like
the next five years who who's that who's
that person gonna be
the last eight weeks or so have been
kind of a gift gift from God in terms of
just like drama and I'm just chopping at
the bit every morning to go and look at
my Twitter app or like to go and look at
the news I'm I'm loving this man this is
a soap opera and I'm on board I said I
was on board originally when uh Elon was
doing Twitter and now like with FTX and
all this other drama
back they got me back like this has just
been awesome it's been a dopamine hit
like every single day you know and I'm
feening I'm waiting for that next hit
every morning I check it and so this has
been just the opposite dude I'm going
the other way I uh I can't resist
sometimes what's that the the is it the
R Kelly thing where he's like my mind's
telling me no he's like
yes sir that's how it feels like my mind
is like this is all a distraction
unrelated to you go read a book go
outside go build something no this is
the opposite of what you stand for go
read a book have you ever read a book in
your life I had your the other day you
told me about a book you were reading
and I was like oh that's great you're
like yeah I'm only five pages in though
you literally were telling me about a
book that you were reading and how
impactful it's been and then the next
sentence was you said that you were five
pages in do you remember that it was
like about like yoga or some [__] it
was like quicker the better
and now you're telling me to get off
Twitter and read a book I didn't know
you read books
when was the last time you read a book
from beginning to end
from beginning to end okay that is that
is a bit of a challenge I read probably
one book a year from beginning to end
and I read probably 10 books
from beginning to 35 pages in a year
that's so funny yeah by the way I think
that's the optimal way to read books
like most books you can get the general
principle and if if it doesn't compel
you to finish it you should have no
problem putting it down saying I took
what I I took what I needed from that
and I'm ready for the next you know
interesting Little Nugget or principle
because these books are a lot of filler
tell me about this this jet thing that
you've had on here twice now by the way
our and so we have this document is
called MDB Master it just stands for
million dollar brainstorm I don't know
if you saw this it's across 200 pages so
we've I'm Sean I have this document that
every day in the morning we like write
our topics it's it's it's 50 000 words
now and 200 Pages for reading we've
deleted I've deleted a bunch of topics
off this like once we're done with that
I just delete them it's pretty wild uh
how long this documented is but you've
had this thing in here about Jets what
what about it okay so um I forgot who
was saying this maybe Andrew Wilkinson
somebody else Andrew he was saying this
about
um empty legs so basically private jets
are obviously really expensive really
awesome have you ever flown private on
your own dime no have you ever flown
private on anyone else's diabeter I flew
private a couple times one time Andrew
paid for it how was it
it was sick like yeah like you know like
there's things that like maybe like um
fancy socks and like that's basically it
that's like things that like it doesn't
matter just buy the cheap ones they're
just as good as the fancy ones and then
there's things where you spend money and
it actually makes a difference and
unfortunately for all the plebs out
there flying private's one of them uh
I'm a plebe too by the way I don't fly
private it costs too much but flying
private it is game changing yeah when I
did it I was like okay this is awesome I
kind of imagine it should be similar to
the strip club experience where I would
constantly feel like I need to be doing
something to like maximize the
opportunity like I can just imagine
myself standing up and just stretching
repeatedly like I don't know am I is
there caviar I don't even like this dude
I read I read a newspaper when I flew
when he flew me I read the Wall Street
Journal I've never read the newspaper in
my life but I picked up the newspaper
and I opened it up I opened it up and
just had it and I and I like flopped it
and like smacked it to like get the
crease out of there that's what I did
when I flew private and it was an
amazing experience
yeah I feel like I would need to like
pick up some new hobbies and like wear
leather if I was gonna be a flying
private so you're gonna get into Sudoku
so he tweeted this thing about empty
legs so basically private jets I think
some really high percentage maybe 25 or
30 of all
private jet flights are completely empty
it's just a jet relocating from one
place to another in order to be ready
for the next flight and so there's this
Arbitrage then of empty empty legs uh
with basically like hey this was gonna
fly anyways it's just gonna cost you
know 40 Grand to do this flight and it's
getting it's you know there's no value
it's just a burn could you basically
give people the opportunity to hop into
these empty legs and so I found there's
a website uh or there's several but like
there are websites that will let you fly
private you don't need to own the plane
you don't need to sign up for some
membership it's literally just like hey
if this is going from here to there if
you want to go 20 grand and it's like
it's this is yours you know you you and
six people can go on this thing
um that's kind of interesting have you
seen have you heard about this no but
one time I I I have a little bit heard
of it and and one time I was like you
know what I'm gonna do I'm just gonna
call the airport so there's one time
that I needed a flight from Nashville to
New York and I just called if you just
Google like your city the city you're in
plus Executive Airport and I remember I
called them I go hey can you put me in
touch with like a like a broker like a
flight broker and they did and I talked
to the I go hey I need to go to New York
in like a few hours tonight is there any
Pilots that need work and can fly me
from Nashville to New York and there was
a guy willing to do it for sixty five
hundred dollars he's like that's you
know that's the cheapest we could do for
6 500 and it was like a like a crazy
hack that I didn't think actually worked
and it did right so like right now uh in
four days from
yeah I'm on uh jetly.com right now but
yeah there's a place in Texas going to
Fort Wayne International in Indiana
it's going there anyways and it's just
as negotiable right you could just like
uh you can go do this or right now like
uh let's see when is this one this is in
two days so in two days if you're in
Poland or you want to go to Italy
um you know fifteen thousand dollars and
you can have this private jet flight uh
if you happen to be going there and you
get the whole plane
yeah I think you get the whole plane
because it's it's empty how many does it
see
uh let's see so you can click I mean is
it like if it's a small one you can see
you know seven people
all right so this is okay this one is
going from
Turner burrow where is that Turtle
burrow to Westport New York New York to
Miami basically okay so New York to
Miami
um Teterboro Teterboro okay uh let's see
this one seats
eight
eight and how much
this uh so the one to Miami's seat six
it's 15 grand so you know basically
that's a price of a first class ticket
right like for for a lot of things yeah
and it'd be a fun ass experience with a
bunch of friends so everyone ponies up
two grand I mean that'd be that's a
pretty cool experience yeah yeah so I
thought this was kind of cool and
another like
kind of this is what Airbnb did was like
they took something that was excess
capacity and found a way to turn it into
like a uh to fill more of that excess
Demand right so do you know um do you
know Dennis Dennis heck said
so he's my good buddy here in Austin and
he once a week he goes hey I just got a
notification Austin to and he'll just
say like somewhere in Utah like it's a
it's a Gulf Stream like you know it's
normally a hundred thousand dollars they
have it for 20 grand and they could see
10 of us you and a bunch of friends want
to go do this thing he does that all the
time and he actually like actually like
pounces on him
um okay so what else we got you got a
couple others um
life after selling you want to do that
all right let's let's this is just an
interesting thing so I always read this
subreddit called fat fire and it's
interesting because you don't know if
anything that fire means uh people who
financially independent retired early so
people who want to uh do that but fats
meaning they want to retire with a lot
of money and not work again and that's
an interesting sentiment like most
everyone wants to do that they go oh I
would love to retire and and be rich and
not have to work at the age of 30. that
sounds cool right
there's this common theme of people
doing that and they get depressed and
that sounds like oh boohoo like why you
know [__] those guys who cares but it's
interesting nonetheless and there's this
really interesting thread that I found
so click where it says follow up yeah
but the reason why this is interesting
is like you are seeing such a such a
clear Journey that someone is
experiencing and so this person wrote a
post where basically about a year ago
they wrote a post saying hey I sold my
company I made 20 million dollars until
that day I hadn't sold a single share I
wasn't living paycheck to paycheck but I
was living a normal life uh after the
sale I basically had nothing to do with
the company
um my wife kept working and she would
just basically tell her friends that I
was working from home but in reality I
was just playing video games all day
while our kids were at school and six
months later uh doing this I am so
depressed I hate my life I have nothing
going on I'm sad I need to go see a
therapist yada yada
he writes another Post 10 months later
and he goes hey this is just a short
follow-up to the post that I previously
wrote but the Crux of it is uh for this
uh this moment in my life is so good I
love waking up I love doing uh what I'm
doing all day and uh it just I feel like
I've got camaraderie and basically what
this guy did was he sold this company
made enough money was depressed for a
little while and did the exact same
thing again where he went and started
another company and he has 10 employees
it's cash flow positive it's not huge
yet but it's enough to pay for the 10
employees and I think it could be big
but what I realized was I loved the hunt
doing it and another person said
my number the amount of money that I
made it wasn't anywhere near yours but I
pulled the trigger and I sold the
company I made a little bit of money and
I basically retired and I float around
in my pool all day I played video games
I read and after about three to four
months I was miserable I was so sad and
now since then I started a small
business it's never going to be that big
but I basically took one of my hobbies
and I turned it into a small business
and it has a lot of challenging problems
and I've never been happier and I
thought
this topic and this these this the red
who knows if it's real everyone could be
exaggerating but it's incredibly
interesting because you get to be a
voyeur and see other people's lives
where they anonymously say their true
feelings and I thought that this was a
really interesting Insight that is
rarely not
uncovered or discussed in such a clear
straightforward way where you see like a
very like post one I'm sad post two I'm
not sad and I thought it was like a
really interesting insight and I went
through this not as much with my company
I I was happy I took I got some chill
time but I went to the same thing I'm
like
what do you do what am I supposed to do
all the time
um and it's actually quite depressing
and it's it's not a topic discussed
because
you know who the [__] wants to talk
about a guy who sold this company
doesn't have to work and now he's sad
but interesting nonetheless and
interesting because a lot of people want
to do this
and it's cool to see that it's maybe not
all that fulfilling and basically
particularly type A's who have the
ability to do this you have to have like
a way to contribute you know like I've
talked to I have a few stay-at-home moms
in my life who like after their kids
went to school they're like my life is
pointless you know like I don't
contribute to anything previously I I
was contributing to my children's lives
now they're in school they don't need me
what the hell am I supposed to do I'm so
sad and now this is like a really good
example of that but in the business
world so I don't know what do you think
about this so I literally had a
conversation like this yesterday with
the guys who were helping set up the
studio they go uh you know
I heard they were saying I heard this
and they said Alex tremozzi said this
too like he he's never been as sad as
after he sold his company he was
depressed kind of like uh either sad or
depressed I I don't know the exact
phrase but basically the same gist of it
sold his company and then that was
supposed to feel the best right but
actually I felt the worst thinking what
do you think about that do you feel that
and I go no I feel excited like I feel
super excited I'm like oh are you joking
like the
anything is possible now right like uh
sure I have you know a bunch of free
time and if if it was always going to be
doing nothing that would be that would
feel a little bit that would feel bad
for sure but
for me I'm very very excited about this
period of oh I get to figure out what's
next and everything is possible and
everything seems interesting and the
background is is you had a project that
you recently sold we'll do a whole pod
on it at another point now you've got
some free time yeah and I've had that
before when we sold uh bibo the first
time and the same thing like you know
I've never felt that but I have heard
this now from a bunch of different
people and
um I remember Michael Birch who's been
on the Pod and was was kind of a mentor
an investor in in my company he he
basically said the same thing uh you
know when he sold bibo for 850 million
dollars
you know next six months we're not not
very fun like you know uh it was like a
huge come down and he's like you can't
even really talk about it because
poor billionaire like what nobody wants
to hear it
um and
I think people take the wrong take away
from this I think what people take away
is oh it's not all that it's cracked up
to be to sell uh you know maybe maybe
that's not a good thing I don't think
that's the right takeaway because I
agree with you I was happy that I did it
and I don't regret it at all and it was
everything plus more that it was cracked
up to be exactly I think the real
takeaway is that
humans need you know a purpose and a
direction where they're going to direct
their talents and their energy and their
focus without that uh you will be sad
and so the question is and and sometimes
in between things you won't know exactly
what that purpose needs to be and that
figure it out period can feel
uncomfortable some people get sad of
that for that period because they they
are so used to having that purpose but
that isn't like it's not just sad equals
bad sometimes it's feeling bad equals
discomfort equals being out of your
comfort zone equals growth and so I
think the the better signal or the
better takeaway is yeah when you when
you do realize that hey man I've been
filling my time and focus and energy
with one thing for so long I take that
away and now I'm going to fill it with
something else something new something
something that can be exciting but the
period where I don't know what that is
that's a little that's a little
uncomfortable and I'm gonna have to go
through that until I could find that
thing again and that's okay that's part
of the process to figure out the right
thing rather than just filling it right
same way that when you break up with
let's say you're in a bad relationship
or even an okay relationship but you
break up because you know it's not the
one you want uh you break up yeah it
kind of sucks to be alone and single
there is a period of time where that
does suck but that suck is required for
you to work on yourself figure out what
you want make space for the next person
and then when you meet that next person
you it's even better than it was before
but it was you couldn't skip that single
step if you just never did that you
would never have the better relationship
in the second time so that's kind of my
the way I think about it at least so I
I'll try to be really tactical here so I
I've got a a handful of friends who made
enough money that you know they're
they're they're pretty much set and they
built these like great companies and
they came from nothing and then they
sell and then they want to start
something again and after six months
they're like oh this can't ever be big
or it's not growing fast enough or it's
just too hard and I'm like
man like had you thought that about the
thing that got you to where you are you
never would have gotten to where you are
like you're kind of being a little punk
and you're being soft and you need to
like get past that and I think that that
is like a really big challenge that
people go through and the way that I
combated that challenge or I I think
I've done a good job over overcoming
that challenges first of all dude
getting that first sale regardless of
what you have I think is awesome like
it's addicting and if it gives you that
dope that uh dopamine high but second
what I did is I took
my lump sum and I invested it uh just
like boring 80 20 you know stocks and
bonds and then I well not entirely 80 20
because I do have like some just in like
a you know just cash sitting there but
that account I haven't logged into in
like a year and a half like I just don't
log into it and I keep a certain amount
of money in my checking account tens of
thousands of dollars and then I have my
credit card and I just assume that my
net worth is tens of thousands of
dollars and so if I want something I've
got to go earn or I'm like well you know
I would love to go and buy x y and z i
better make my company work a little bit
better or uh you know I think about it
like that and that has been a nice
little hack that has helped me kind of
like like that a little silly though
right because it's like um
then the money is serving you no purpose
no utility
well it it why do you want the money so
bad if it wasn't going to benefit you
well because first the the cash flow
that I make on a monthly basis covers my
life and more so pretty much I know that
you don't even look at that account
no so the way I have it set up is a
certain amount of my cash flow goes to
my checking account and that's my
spending money that's the account with
tens of thousands of dollars and then
one but once it hits a threshold it
automatically goes to my other account
which is my investment account that I
don't log into right one thing is the
investment account then is serving you
no purpose is it not improving the
quality of your life at all well yes and
no yes and the fact that like when I got
my deal done I wanted a car and I wanted
a house I bought those things and I
didn't really and then I wanted to buy
some clothes I think I bought like two
or three thousand dollars or maybe more
worth of clothing and I was like all
right like that that's like pretty much
all I I don't really want much else and
oh and I took a trip it was a ten
thousand dollar trip to Hawaii and so
collectively that sum my car was a
hundred and ten thousand dollars it
wasn't like crazy expensive but it was
kind of expensive collectively like I
spent that amount of money like buying
the initial things that I wanted and
then after that I was like you know I
don't really want more stuff I don't
want more things and so it served me but
now I don't want more stuff and if I
would if I do want something extra in
the back of my head I know look I could
go and get the money to spend it but I'd
rather just go and earn that because
that keeps me hungry and it's kind of
more exciting and more fun and I
appreciate it more so in my brain on one
on one hand I think I only have I'm only
worth sixty thousand dollars or 79
thousand dollars because that's what's
in my checking account
but in reality I'm like yeah when
emergencies happen with my family it's
all covered but I try to just look at
that sixty thousand or seventy thousand
and that's all I have
okay I like that that makes sense but
you don't like that
um no I like it I think it's good I like
using I do this a lot I use my own
psychology for me rather than against me
it's much easier to just understand how
your brain works and then use it to your
benefit then try to fight the way your
brain works and say no brain
think differently and react differently
to situations you know what I mean it's
like the same way that if I publicly go
on here and say I'm gonna do something
then I know that my brain is going to
not want to
fail at that because the social pressure
is going to make me want to do it so I
just use that to my advantage I'll go
and I'll say I'm gonna do the X and I
call my shot because now I know I'm
going to use that feeling of social
pressure to help me do the thing I want
rather than try to talk myself out of
caring what other people think
no I I think that's a good way to live
I'm I'm we're gonna do it this is the
second time we said it so we actually
have to do it but we're gonna have to do
a total pod about like what you're going
to do next but I think that
I think the best thing that people like
you uh and me and people who sell stuff
the best part of the situation is okay I
have a I have a little while to breathe
and think no one very rarely do people
get that sometimes they'll get it if
they get fired and they get severance
but most people the average American
doesn't get it until they retire if if
they can retire and even then it's like
dude I'm now I'm old and like I don't
right I don't have a lot of income
coming in so it's like what you know
what's the point but uh so I think the
best part of selling is you have time to
reflect and think the worst part is if
it if you do that for too long you get
stale and you're gonna I think you have
a highly likelihood of being depressed
and sad
yeah the uh we we've used that phrase
before work like a lion I think I think
Naval was the one who came up with this
but like you know a lot it's worth
repeating because I think that this is
this is what you're describing a lion
will
find what it wants right it finds its
prey it Sprints it catches it then it
feasts and it toasts and it celebrates
you know the that that feast
then it relaxes it sits and it waits you
know there's a rest period and then
there's a observing period where it
lurks and it waits for the next prey and
so his business is the same right you
had a period And I had a period where we
were sprinting
to catch the the other win we both
caught the win
then we feasted we celebrated we did the
you know got that out of our system it's
important to enjoy it's important to
learn how to enjoy everything
then you rest and you reassess and you
go and you're looking for the next prey
and then for you you just found your
next one and you started sprinting and
I'm still in the I'm in the uh the rest
and and reassess period and that's what
I told you was enjoy that rest though
you you have to you do have to enjoy it
I think you truly do need like a period
to rest and like embrace it which I know
is very hard for you and most people no
that's easy for me that's what I'm
saying uh I get when other people say
that's difficult for them but like it
sounds to me like a snow flaky thing to
be sad about like not to like minimize
your feelings like I kind of get it but
no what I mean is like it's like what's
your it's like what's your perspective
it's like my perspective is like dude I
can't like I'm so happy with how that
turned out
um that was awesome the next thing is
going to be awesome and a this period is
a new it's a different type of season in
the same way that oh it's nice in the
winter because you kind of bundle up and
you wear your your fuzzy socks and you
you sip on your hot cocoa or whatever
it's a different season and that's to be
enjoyed for its own purposes and like
you know I don't feel bad for myself and
then and therefore I don't want anybody
else to feel bad in the same way like I
think
people
too easily are willing to feel bad about
themselves or feel bad for themselves or
to themselves or whatever like it's like
a form of victimhood right like
um I understand how it would be easy to
think that way but I do not
think that way I choose not
no I I guess what I mean is you have a
pattern sometimes
of jumping into projects and going all
in and I'm like you know like maybe just
like if you have an idea just wait like
three weeks and then and then and then
do it you know
yeah like you know like I you started
the milk Road over a weekend you're like
well you're you're all in on one or two
other things and then over the weekend
we're like I'm doing this and you went
all in on it and thankfully it worked
but
you could see how that could be both an
advantage and a disadvantage but that
that's kind of the point that I think is
is very very Sage advice for me uh
because it's super easy to start
something you can start something in an
hour
but once you start something and if it's
going to do anything it's going to take
weeks or months to make it work to get
it started and then once it's working
now it's years to like you know pay it
off particularly a daily email that
requires you to do something every
single day daily emails are hard aren't
they I mean they're not that hard but
they're they're challenging they're
unlike other businesses but even if it
wasn't the daily email I guess either
way starting is so much easier than
finishing that like you got to be
careful that like just because it would
be easy to get it to try uh it's like
the test is if I'm gonna do something
it's a it's a it's a multi-year Arc for
if this is going to be a good in a good
scenario so Choose Wisely you know that
those are very very valuable years of uh
of prime prime and same thing with
people taking jobs or anything else it's
like are you sure you sure you're gonna
give up like 20 of your Prime to that or
like people who want to wait I'm gonna
wait a year before I go do the thing I
want are you sure a year right you know
valuable that year is to you like this
year in your 20s you know what that's
worth like that's not just like uh
that's not that's not nothing right like
a year in your 20s is I kind of think
like you're sort of like 20 20 to kind
of like your 50s basically that 30-year
window
is you know worth like 80 percent of the
time of the total time in your life and
so like you know each of those years is
uh is very very valuable do not do not
uh do not throw it away doing something
you don't want to do
I'm I'm eager to hear if people like
this type of content but uh
I think they will right what do you
think yeah again if we like it they'll
like it who are our customers the people
that love what we do all right we should
uh we should wrap it up
[Music]